HEAVY EQUIPMENT HAVE NOW
OFFICIALLY ROLLED INTO EASTERN
UKRAINE.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS UNDERWAY WITH
THIS VERY DEFEATED, FRANKLY
DEFEATED JOE BIDEN AND HUNKERED
OUT TO THE PODIUM 90 MINUTES
LATE TO DELIVER THESE VERY
UNINSPIRING REMARKS, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> IF RUSSIA GOES FURTHER WITH
THIS INVASION, WE STAND TO GO
REPAIRED WITH SANCTIONS.
WHO IN THE LORD'S NAME DO PUTIN
THINK GIVES HIM THE RIGHT TO
DECLARE NEW SO-CALLED COUNTRIES
ON TERRITORY THAT BELONG TO HIS
NEIGHBORS?
YESTERDAY, VLADIMIR PUTIN
TWISTED TO REWRITE HISTORY.
AND GOING BACK A CENTURY AS HE
WAXED ELOQUENTLY.
KNOWING -- WELCOME I'M NOT GOING
TO GO INTO DETAILS.
AND NO INTEREST TO PURSUE YOUR
OWN.
IN THE YEAR 2022.
>> NO DOUBT VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
SHAKING IN HIS BOOTS, THIS IS
REALLY BEYOND EMULATING OUR
COUNTRY.
OF COURSE, BIDEN DID ANNOUNCE
NEW SANCTIONS TODAY BUT ONE TOP
DIPLOMATIC MOSCOW DOES NOT GIVE
A ADAM SCHIFF ABOUT SANCTIONS.
THE MAIN SOURCE OF REVENUE IS IN
THE FORM OF THE PRODUCTION OF
OIL AND GAS.
CHINA, THEY BUY TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF THIS GAS AND SO DOES
WESTERN EUROPE, OUR ALLIES
PRODUCING IT FOR THEM AND MAKING
MONEY AND CREATING JOBS AND
LOWERING THIS 40 YEAR HIGH UP
INFLATION.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THAT OIL AND
GAS WILL CONTINUE TO FLOW NO
MATTER WHAT RUSSIA DOES TOO
UKRAINE.
IN FACT MUCH OF RUSSIA,
ESPECIALLY GERMANY ARE DEPENDENT
ON RUSSIA OIL AND GAS WHICH IS A
BIG PART OF THIS PROBLEM.
LAST YEAR EVEN AMERICA, OUR
COUNTRY JOE BIDEN'S FIRST YEAR
IN OFFICE IMPORTED A WHOPPING
230 MILLION BARRELS OF OIL TO
RUSSIA.
PUTIN RUSSIA HAS BEEN BEGGING
REPEATEDLY AND REJECTED
REPEATEDLY TO PRODUCE MORE OIL
TO DRIVE DOWN THE PRICE OF OIL.
THE PRICE OF A GALLON OF
GASOLINE.
WE HAVE MORE THAN THEY HAVE.
WHY DON'T WE PRODUCE IT
OURSELVES, JOE?
THIS IS MADNESS.
THIS IS INSANITY.
MANY OF THE WORLD'S LEADERS HAVE
BEEN PERFECTLY HAPPY TO MAKE
PUTIN AND RUSSIA DON'T MAKE
RUSSIA RICH AGAIN AND SUPPLY OF
ENERGY AVAILABLE FOR ALL.
NOW IN 2018, WE WILL SHOW YOU AN
EPIC FACE TO FACE COMPLETE BEAT
DOWN WITH THEN PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP REBUKING EUROPEAN
LEADERS, GETTING RIGHT IN THEIR
FACE FOR THEIR DEPENDENTS ON
RUSSIA FOR THEIR ENERGY, HELPING
MAKE RUSSIA RICH AGAIN WHILE WE
PAID THE BILL FOR NATO TO
PROTECT THEM FROM RUSSIA.
IT IS A LONG CLIP.
IT IS WORTH WATCHING.
WHILE YOU'RE WATCHING, ASK
YOURSELF "DO YOU THINK JOE BIDEN
COULD EVER BE CAPABLE OF THIS
LEVEL OF PASSIONATE FIGHTING TO
WHAT IS IN OUR COUNTRY'S BEST
INTEREST?"
HERE IS THE FULL EXCHANGE.
>> IT IS VERY SAD WHEN GERMANY
MAKES A MASSIVE OIL AND GAS DEAL
WITH RUSSIA WHERE YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE GUARDING AGAINST
RUSSIA IN GERMANY GOES OUT AND
PAYS BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR TO RUSSIA.
SO WE ARE PROTECTING GERMANY.
WE ARE PROTECTING FRANCE.
WE ARE PROTECTING ALL OF THESE
COUNTRIES.
IN THE COUNTRY'S GO OUT AND MAKE
A PIPELINE DEAL WITH RUSSIA WHEN
THEY ARE PAYING BILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE GOVERNMENT.
YOU AGAINST RUSSIA BUT THEY ARE
PAYING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
RUSSIA.
I THINK THAT IS VERY
INAPPROPRIATE.
THE FORMER CHANCELLOR OF GERMANY
IS AHEAD OF THE PIPELINE THE
PIPELINE OF GAS.
SO ULTIMATELY, GERMANY WILL HAVE
ALMOST 70% OF THE COUNTRY
CONTROLLED BY RUSSIA WITH
NATURAL GAS.
YOU TELL ME.
IS THAT APPROPRIATE?
I'VE BEEN COMPLAINING ABOUT THIS
FROM THE TIME I GOT IN HERE.
IT SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
ALLOWED TO HAPPEN.
GERMANY IS SOLELY CONTROLLED BY
RUSSIA.
BECAUSE THEY WILL GET 60%, 70%
OF THEIR ENERGY FROM RUSSIA AS A
NEW PIPELINE.
YOU TELL ME IF THAT IS
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE I THINK IT
IS NOT.
AND I THINK NATO COME I DON'T
THINK IT SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
I THINK WE HAVE TO TALK TO
GERMANY ABOUT IT.
ON TOP OF THAT, GERMANY IS
PAYING A LITTLE BIT OVER 1%
TOWARDS THE UNITED STATES AND
ACTUAL NUMBERS 4.2%.
MUCH LARGER GDP.
SO I THINK THAT IS INAPPROPRIATE
ALSO.
WE ARE PROTECTING GERMANY.
WE ARE PROTECTING FRANCE.
WE ARE PROTECTING EVERYBODY,
YET, WE ARE PAYING A LOT OF
MONEY TO PROTECT.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
DECADES AND BROUGHT UP BY OTHER
PRESIDENTS.
BUT OTHER PRESIDENTS NEVER DID
ANYTHING ABOUT IT BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THEY UNDERSTOOD IT
OR JUST DIDN'T WANT TO GET
INVOLVED.
BUT I HAVE TO BRING IT UP
BECAUSE IT IS VERY UNFAIR TO HER
COUNTRY AND VERY UNFAIR TO THE
TAXPAYER.
I THINK THESE COUNTRIES HAVE TO
STEP IT UP NOT OVER A TEN-YEAR
PERIOD.
GERMANY IS A RICH COMPANY.
THEY TALK ABOUT INCREASING JUST
A TINY BIT, BY 2030, WELL, THEY
COULD INCREASE IT IMMEDIATELY
TOMORROW AND HAVE NO PROBLEM.
I DON'T THINK IT IS FAIR TO THE
UNITED STATES.
SO, WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO PUT UP WITH
IT.
WE CAN'T PUT UP WITH IT.
IT IS INAPPROPRIATE.
SO THE DOLLARS BEING PAID TO
PROTECTING YOU AGAINST.
EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT IT
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTING
YOU FROM RUSSIA, BUT WHY ARE YOU
PAYING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
RUSSIA FOR ENERGY?
WHY OR COUNTRIES IN NATO, MAINLY
GERMANY, HAVING A LOST
PERCENTAGE OF ENERGY TO RUSSIA
AND TAKING CARE OF BY RUSSIA?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, GERMANY IS
THE CAPTIVE OF RUSSIA BECAUSE
THEY SUPPLY IT AND GET RID OF
COAL AND NUCLEAR.
THEY ARE GETTING SO MUCH OIL AND
GAS FROM RUSSIA.
I THINK IT IS SOMETHING THAT
NATO HAS TO LOOK AT.
I THINK IT IS VERY
INAPPROPRIATE.
YOU AND I AGREE IT IS
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU CAN DO
ABOUT IT NOW, BUT IT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE SENSE THAT
THEY PAY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
RUSSIA AND THAT WE HAVE TO
DEFEND THEM AGAINST RUSSIA.
>> THE UNITED NATIONS, THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES AND ALSO SOME
DISAGREEMENTS ON THE PIPELINE IN
GERMANY AND ONE ISSUE THE ALLIES
AT LEAST AGREE.
BUT DESPITE THESE DIFFERENCES,
YOU'LL HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO
UNITE TO PROTECT AND DEFEND EACH
OTHER.
WE UNDERSTAND WE ARE STRONGER
TOGETHER THAN APART.
BUT I THINK THAT IS THAT WE ARE
STRONGER TOGETHER THAN APART.
>> WHEN A COUNTRY IS GETTING ITS
ENERGY FROM THE PERSON YOU WANT
PROTECTION AGAINST OR YOU WANT
TO GET PROTECTION.
>> WHEN WE STAND TOGETHER, BUT
ALSO RUSSIA, WE ARE STRONGER.
>> NO, WE ARE MAKING RUSSIA
RICHARD.
WE ARE MAKING RUSSIA RICHER.
>> EVEN IN THE COLD WAR, NATO
ALLIES, DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT OPEN
DISTINCT]
>> THE ENERGY IS A MUCH
DIFFERENT STORY.
AND POLAND, ON EXCEPT THE GAS.
AND YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
COUNTRIES AND THEY WON'T ACCEPT
IT BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
CAPTIVE TO RUSSIA.
GERMANY, AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED
IS CAPTIVE TO RUSSIA BECAUSE
IT'S GETTING SO MUCH ENERGY FROM
RUSSIA.
SO WE ARE SUPPOSED TO PROTECT
GERMANY, BUT THEY ARE GETTING
THEIR ENERGY FROM RUSSIA.
EXPLAINED THAT.
AND IT CAN'T BE EXPLAINED, YOU
KNOW THAT.
>> Sean: A DISTANT NO-NO'S
RIGHT IN THE FACE OF NATO
LEADER.
YOU THINK JOE BIDEN COULD DO
THAT?
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO, YOU SIGN THAT VIDEO
AND MORE OF THAT EXCHANGE LATER
IN THE SHOW TONIGHT.
CLEARLY, TRUMP WAS ABSOLUTELY
DEAD ON ACCURATE.
COMPARE THAT TO JOE BIDEN
SELF-PROCLAIMED TOUGH GUY,
FOREIGN POLICY EXPERTS,
TOE-TO-TOE WITH PUTIN.
HE PROMISED TO STOP PUTIN IN HIS
TRACKS.
PUTIN COULD BARELY FORM A
SENTENCE AS USUAL AND UNWILLING
AND UNABLE TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ALL RIGHT, WELL, THANK YOU.
YOU'VE GOT TO LET ME KNOW WHEN
I'M SUPPOSED TO STOP HERE.
SYLVIA, WHERE IS SYLVIA?
HOW ARE YOU, SYLVIA?
>> Sean: WE HAVE A MUMBLING,
BUMBLING BUFFOON AS PRESIDENT.
TOMORROW, JOE HAS ZERO EVENT
SCHEDULED, NONE WHATSOEVER.
THAT DOESN'T EXACTLY INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE PRESS SECRETARY JEN PSAKI,
SHE KNOWS WHO TO BLAME FOR
RUSSIANS AGGRESSION.
LESS BLAME DONALD TRUMP.
REALLY, IT JEN PSAKI, LET'S TAKE
A LOOK.
DO YOU HAVE FORMER REACTION TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN YESTERDAY?
>> WELL HIM AS A MATTER OF
POLICY, WE TRY NOT TO TAKE
ADVICE FROM ANYONE WHO PRAISES
PRESIDENT PUTIN MILITARY
STRATEGY, WHICH I BELIEVE IS
WHAT HAPPENED THERE.
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT TACTIC AND A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT APPROACH AND
THAT IS WHY PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
NOT HIS PREDECESSOR TO RALLY THE
WORLD AND THE GLOBAL COMMUNITY
IN TAKING STEPS AGAINST RUSSIANS
AGGRESSION.
>> Sean: HEY, JEN PSAKI THIS
WOULD NOT HAPPEN UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOUR BOSS WITH ENERGY
INDEPENDENT POLICIES, JOE IS
HUMILIATING OUR ENTIRE COUNTRY
ON THE WORLD STAGE.
HE IS GETTING ROLLED BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN AND IT IS
EMBARRASSING AND BARELY STRING
TOGETHER A SENTENCE.
I DOUBT IF EVEN KNOWS WHAT DAY
OF THE WEEK IT IS, JOE ROGAN
EVEN SAID BIDEN IS BASICALLY A
COGNITIVE SHELL HIS FORMER SELF.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> DAY KNOW HE UNDERSTANDS HOW
THE SENATE WORKS SO DOES THAT
NOT COUNT HIS EXPERIENCE?
IT KIND OF DOES, BUT HE WAS
ACTUALLY VICE PRESIDENT FOR
EIGHT YEARS, BUT HE'S NOT A GOOD
EXAMPLE BECAUSE HE IS BASICALLY
A SHELL.
YOU KNOW, COGNITIVELY.
>> YOU DON'T SEE THIS GUY CAN'T
TALK RIGHT ANYMORE?
GO WATCH VIDEOS OF HIM FOR 20
YEARS AGO.
HE IS A DUMMY.
HE'S SAID A LOT OF LEAP AND HE
LIED ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS BUT
AT LEAST HE WAS ARTICULATE.
>> Sean: JOE ROGAN WE HAVE
SHOWN VIDEOS 2008, 2012, 2016,
BUT HE NOTICES THE OBVIOUS
COGNITIVE DECLINE.
OUR FRIENDS KNOW IT AND
UNFORTUNATELY OUR ENEMIES ALSO
KNOW IT AND THAT INCLUDES
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HERE IS AN IMPORTANT QUESTION,
WHERE DID PUTIN TERRITORIAL
AMBITIONS END?
BECAUSE 2008 PUTIN INVADED
GEORGIA AND SET UP PUBLIC
GOVERNMENT AND SO-CALLED --
BELLA ROSE, RIGHT?
AND UNDER OBAMA IN 2014 REMEMBER
THAT IS WHEN THEY ANNEXED
CRIMEA.
HE'S ROLLING INTO EASTERN RUANE
WITH TFN'S CROSSHAIRS.
WHAT IS NEXT BASED ON PUBLIC
REMARKS HE SEEMS PRETTY
HELL-BENT ON RESTORING THE OLD
SOVIET UNION.
RECENTLY, PUTIN ADDED THE BALTIC
COUNTRIES TO OFFICIAL LIST OF
SO-CALLED UNFRIENDLY NATIONS.
SO WHAT WILL THEY SOON BE
TARGETS OF VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
TERRITORIAL AMBITIONS?
AND IF THEY ARE, WHAT IS JOE
GOING TO DO ABOUT IT?
ONE ARTICLE PUT IT THIS WAY
"BALTIC CITIZENS WHERE THEY ARE
NEXT ON THE MENU.
THE BALTIC STATES ARE MEMBERS OF
NATO SO DOES THAT MEAN THE U.S.
WOULD BE DRAWN INTO A WAR?
I HOPE CERTAINLY HOPE AND PRAY
NOT ESPECIALLY WITH THIS GUY
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF BUT AS YOU
CAN SEE, THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO SPIRAL WAY OUT OF CONTROL
VERY QUICKLY.
WEAKNESS SHOULD NOT BE AN
OPTION.
THIS IS GERMANY, NATO, EUROPE,
WESTERN ALLIES TO BREAK FREE ON
RUSSIA OIL AND GAS.
THE ONLY ANSWER, THE ONLY
COUNTRY THAT HAS MORE NATURAL
RESOURCES, OIL, GAS, COAL, THAT
WOULD BE US.
THE UNITED STATES.
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO BEAT
PUTIN, WE WILL NOT HAVE A
SHOOTING WAR WITH PUTIN.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE ONE.
WE SHOULD FLOOD THE MARKET WITH
OUR OWN ENERGY SUPPLY THAT WILL
HELP INFLATION, HIGH PAYING
CAREER JOBS, GOOD FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY, AND TIME FOR EUROPE TO
GET SERIOUS ABOUT NATO.
THEY MUST PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
THEY MUST TAKE THEIR OWN DEFENSE
SERIOUSLY.
THEY MUST DETER FUTURE
TRANSGRESSIONS FROM RUSSIA.
THEY MUST STOP MAKING RUSSIA AND
PUTIN RICHER THAN EVER.
OF COURSE, THAT WOULD REQUIRE
BOLD LEADERSHIP.
RIGHT NOW, THE WORLD IS MISSING
THE U.S. PRESIDENT WITH A
BACKBONE.
SADLY, JOE BIDEN IS NOT DOING A
GOOD JOB.
GRIFFIN HAS BEEN VERY, VERY,
VERY ARTICULATE AND EXPRESSING
THE URGENCY OF THIS MOMENT.
SHE WILL JOIN US IN A MOMENT,
BUT A QUICK FLASHBACK.
1980, 42 YEARS AGO TODAY, THE
U.S. MEN'S HOCKEY TEAM, REMEMBER
THEY UPSET HEAVILY FAVORED
RUSSIAN TEAM AND ULTIMATELY ONE
COLD.
REMEMBER THE HIT MOVIE "MIRACLE
ON ICE" JUST TO REMIND YOU?
>> HUGE UNDERDOG.
>> 11 SECONDS, TEN SECONDS, THE
COUNTDOWN IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW!
FIVE SECONDS LEFT!
YES!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: 42 YEARS AND NOW ONE
OF THE MOST EPIC SPORTS COALS OF
ALL TIME.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN MIRACLES?
WE NEED ONE NOW.
A FEW SHORT YEARS LATER THE
BERLIN WALL WOULD COME CRASHING
DOWN.
THE COLD WAR WOULD BE OVE